la christopher était en classe de
troisième il avait 16 ans on a appris
qu'il sait faire cela pendant quatre
années
ça a été des brimades des tués gros tu
es à [ __ ] parce qu'il faisait du cheval
il était champion départemental
c'était dans la classe c'était au vu et
au su de tout le monde pour beaucoup de
professeurs aussi ont entendu c'était à
l'école c'était sur les réseaux sociaux
il y avait un groupe classe on l'a
traité de tous les noms christophe en a
eu marre il a il s'est pendu le 17 avril
2010 est à la maison
c'est horrible enfin vous en a parlé
avant christopher nous en a jamais parlé
jamais parlé
il nous a montré en fait maintenant avec
l'association on
s'aperçoit que nos enfants nous parlent
mais en fait c'est nous qui ne
comprenait qu'il comprenons pas
leur
voile alors de ce service qui les fasse
qui nous lancent les alertes qui vous
lancez-vous les voilà vous les voulez
captait pas non il avait des maux de
ventre il est revenu avec un gros bleu
au niveau de la cuisse ils nous lancent
des signaux mais nous on n'arrive pas à
les capter quoi et c'est horrible et
c'est vrai que grâce à l'émission
j'étais venu avec mon avocate on
attendait toujours notre dossier et
bizarrement je voulais apprendre quand
même vu venir le jeudi le mardi mon
avocate a le dossier dans le dans son
casier quand même ça faisait des mois et
des mois qu'on attend dé notre dossier
et au final malgré toutes les preuves
puisque on a des captures d'écran on a
des témoignages on a quand même beaucoup
de preuves et bizarrement notre comme
100% des cas malheureusement notre
dossier a été transmis leurs soeurs
n'ont rien eu rien là les harceleurs
n'ont rien eu
le la direction enfin l'établissement
n'a rien eu non plus ils continuent leur
vie ben comme tout le monde leur vie est
brisée voilà nous la seule chose qu'on a
c'est aller au cimetière
voir notre fils quoi c'est incroyable
sait encore rien du tout est calé
qu'est-ce qu'ils évoquent pour dire qu'
ils peuvent pas vais poursuivre les
harceleurs c'est quoi le sétois qui
était évoqué rien un sans suite on a
voilà une feuille aucune explication
aucune explication votre avocate vous ai
dit quoi vous à dire c'est ne rien là on
comment on va faire appel bien les
violences parce que ça va faire presque
enfin le dossier ça va faire presque
quatre ans maintenant mais c'est très
très long en plus voilà on commence à en
apprendre de plus en plus il n'y avait
pas que le harcèlement moral on a appris
que christopher on lui a demandé de
baisser son pantalon dans les toilettes
il a eu des coups on a appris que
c'était des défis dans la classe et
enfin dans l'établissement l'a
dernièrement on a su christopher devait
faire une fellation non mais là c'est
pas possible qu'ils soient pas
poursuivis pour ça ben faut l'épreuve
mais malheureusement les jeunes comment
vous l'avez du pouvoir voilà on vient
nous voir donc c'est des témoignages
dollars mais ils ne veulent pas
témoigner parce qu'ils ont des pressions
ils ont peur de témoigner et c'est ça
qu'il faut qu'il nous faut changer quoi
on en apprend de plus en plus on a
on a créé un groupe de parents par ange
de d'enfants qui ont mis fin à leurs
jours et une 19e victime depuis le à
l'avenir mais là c'est vraiment les
parents de il ya 3 4 ans et
le témoignage qu'on a vu dans votre
émission
hier soir
c'est un crève coeur pour nous aussi
parce qu'on on
je pense que je pense c'est que vous
avez témoigné le chagrine je sais que
vous avez témoignés ici justement pour
que ça se reproduise plus voilà et
aujourd'hui vous voyez le témoignage
hier et vous vous dites en plus c'est ce
que vous savez que c'est ce qu'on disait
hier avec avec l'amant de dina et son
frère ont dit que dina effet et c'est
vraiment s'est fait tout tout ce qu'il
fallait puisque elle est au courant dès
le début elle a été voir les professeurs
elle a été voir la cpe et c'est vrai
qu'on se dit c'est pas possible c'était
si c'est pas possible on arrive à une
telle issue
ça vous a fait mal hier de voir sous
témoigne louis c'est ce que je disais je
parle là en tant que parents qui n'ont
pas pu venir avec moi ce soir c'est un
crève coeur d'entendre ça on a
l'impression de revivre le le suicide de
notre propre enfant
on regarde ce témoignage et 11 i bat c
c'est christopher c'est pauline haas et
yolan cema elle s'est tous ces jeunes
qui sont partis et et ça continue ça
continue encore et encore jusqu'à ce
qu'un jour enfin il va vraiment falloir
faire quelque chose parce que on peut
pas nous parents
qui ont cette perte d'un enfant on peut
plus supporter ça c'est pas possible
faut vraiment que ça s'arrête ayant il y
en a vraiment marre
je sais pas ce que vous allez pouvoir
nous dire mais il va
falloir que vous avez vous avez monté
une association wim harcèlement est
exactement aujourd'hui c'est que la
question que je pose à chaque fois parce
qu'ils christopher est parti en 2017
vous avez d'autres enfants oui trois
autres trois enfants
quand vous faites toute la famille pour
vous reconstruire pour eux est ce que
vous y pensez tous les jours est ce que
votre vie nnent bien sûr n'est plus la
même depuis non depuis ce jour d'avril
2010 est on y pense tous les jours ça
brise une famille c'est sûr que ma fille
a été obligée de partir du jour au
lendemain de la maison puisqu'elle a
retrouvé son propre frère à l'âge de 18
ans
ça brise une famille tout entière parce
qu'on ne comprend pas
nous on en parle régulièrement les
proches préfèrent
concèze
ça pose beaucoup de problèmes dans tous
les sens du terme et une fille 18 dont
les autres enfants quel âge oui enfin
maintenant montaigne est la vàd de 24
ans maintenant 97
kylie ann
99 et blanches marie va avoir la 16 ans
de 2001 et blanches marie vous et vous
vous êtes encore plus vigilante avec
elle en fait très attention au sein et
elle mute aussi contre le harcèlement
elle a même été exclu du collège
christopher était oui enfin on a tout
fait pour vous parce que l'été dont même
collège que christopher elle a voulu
rentrer quand même l'année de son décès
dans ce collège oui pour par rapport à
son âge
lutter aussi contre le harcèlement quoi
et
est peut-être en mémoire de son frère
aussi je suis en fait il n'y a rien eu
de fait et puis bon c'est vrai que ça a
été médiatisé et du coup le collège a
été contre nous pour plein de choses on
a eu une ip / blanche marion donc les
services sociaux enfin une catastrophe